[Music]
all right let's bring in a bench bureau
he's the editor in chief of the Daily
wires syndicated columnist host of the
Ben Shapiro showed raises from Mariette
today at West Tennessee actually
well that's west of where we are Ben
let's talk a little bit about the
president United States he was talking
the other day the Rose Garden about
whether or not he had called the family
members of the for service personnel
killed in the country of Niger a few
weeks ago and then he mentioned that
President Obama didn't call everybody
and that caused a big media firestorm
now there's a story that apparently he
did call one of the widows of US Army
sergeant Lee David Johnson a couple of
days ago and congresswoman from Florida
Frederika of Wilson a Democrat was
infuriated that the president was so
insensitive because reportedly the
president said the soldier you know your
husband knew what he signed up for but I
guess it still hurts what's your
observation about what's going on with
this because suddenly a greevey a phone
call from the commander in chief to a
grieving family looks like it has been
politicized mommy
here's the big problem is that the only
accounts of the phone call that we have
so far is actually from Frederico Wilson
and this Democratic Congress person was
calling for Trump's impeachment back in
May so the media immediately picked up
on her accounts of the conversation she
was apparently in the car and heard the
conversation on speakerphone but we
haven't heard anything from the widow of
the service member we haven't heard
president Trump's version we haven't
heard the transcript we haven't heard
tapes we haven't heard anything except
for a Democrat who has some political
motivations here particularly in the 48
hours after Trump suggested that
President Obama didn't call all of the
families of troops and somehow that was
a shortcoming so it's a little bit
convenient that this story pops up now
that's not to say that he didn't say
these things but I would like to see
some evidence before the media
immediately jumps to the conclusion that
fulfills all of the things they wanted
to yeah let's book a nine person panel
and debate what a bad person the
president is this woman makes Maxine
Waters seem like a supporter of Donald
Trump some of the headlines in the past
Miami correspondent to Donald Trump
please do not a car congresswoman to
Donald Trump stop tweeting rich she said
what calls for his impeachment
she also says he is desperate for
attention and needs psychological help
this was leading up to the fact that she
witnessed on speakerphone the portion of
a conversation where regarding the
family of a slain soldier I believe
she's got an axe to grind
maybe she's a hundred percent right but
the background makes you at least be
skeptical if you're questioning all
right yeah well I mean if you're gonna
be in a he-said she-said situation then
you have to wonder about the credibility
of the various characters and this is
why I'm saying anyone in fair mind
should at this point be saying okay
let's see some actual evidence of the
conversation TECA in transcript tape how
about the widow herself testifying as to
what exactly happened in this
conversation because even in Wilson's
recounting of the conversation right
there's some ellipses that do some
pretty heavy lifting she says basically
the Trump said you know he knew what he
signed up for but I guess it still feels
bad but there's an ellipses between I
knew what he said he knew what he signed
up for but I guess it still feels bad
the the ellipses there could be some as
you said right the ellipses could be
something like a response directly to
the widows and something the widow said
so we just don't know Ben we put the
picture of this guy he's very young he
leaves behind a wife I don't know if he
has kids
he probably leaves behind parents here's
this picture look how young he is look
how handsome he is he died for our
country and we're talking about this can
we not talk about the service and the
sacrifice that this man made well again
I think that you know if the
conversation went exactly as Wilson said
that would be somewhat troubling because
I don't think the president should
really be saying that sort of thing but
I don't think that we have the evidence
to suggest that and and obviously I
think everyone is is devastated about
the loss of sergeant Johnson the idea
that that President Trump was sitting in
the White House and he really doesn't
care what happened to sergeant Johnson
that seems to me a very convenient
political narrative as I say arising 48
hours after Trump seemingly suggested
something like that about president we
don't know the conversation but do you
really think the president would call up
the widow and say let's preach that
narrative instead of saying I'm sorry
well the the end to your earlier point
where you know you haven't we haven't
heard from the family per se but we did
hear from the Pres
earlier and he said he the tweet was
Democratic congressman totally
fabricated what I said to the wife of a
soldier who died in action and I have
proof so the big question is will he
reveal and then he writes sad will he
reveal that proof will we hear from the
family these are normal conversations
between a commander-in-chief and
agreement family we never ever hear
about until today
all right let's change gears and talk
about Hillary Clinton who by the way is
in South Korea saying the president is
causing war with North Korea totally
irresponsible she also made clear she
doesn't want to run against the
president again but you'll continue to
harass him and continue to criticize him
and now we find out the Clinton
Foundation as its link with the Russians
they revealed to have routed millions of
dollars to Hillary Clinton's while she
was Secretary of State to the Clinton
Foundation and next thing you know she
ends up the Russia ends up with a lot of
our uranium any coincidence there well I
mean Peter Schweitzer detailed this
during the campaign and it was a major
scandal was something the president
Trump brought up on the campaign trail
but what we're finding out now is that
the Obama Department of Justice knew
full well that there was attempted
corruption by the Russian government in
these specific deals and they did
nothing about it so you do have to
wonder why isn't Eric Holder being
called before Congress right now why
isn't he being called on by the new DOJ
to to answer some questions about why
they didn't do anything why they didn't
even apparently what the State
Department know if that's what happened
all of this is deeply suspicious we
already know that the Department of
Justice under Loretta Lynch was making
moves on behalf of Hillary Clinton was
the Department of Justice on behalf of
Hillary Clinton making moves under Eric
Holder as well that would protected some
sort of cash pipeline between the
Russians and the Clinton Foundation
again a lot of the documents that have
been uncovered by the hill are pretty
disturbing from what the helll reports
and the idea that the the Obama
administration was willing to greenlight
this sort of activity knowing full well
that the Russians were attempting to
infiltrate the supply of nuclear
materials is really really disturbing
stuff absolutely and the more they dig
into the Russia thing the more
embarrassing it could be for the Obama
administration Ben thank you very much
for joining us today from Knoxville
Tennessee
thanks so much you bet